hi there yeah day 83 they didn't get a
lot done I must admit someone asked me
about my sweater I wear it a lot yes
this is the sweater I wear around the
house it's got little spots on it that I
don't bother cleaning it's kind of
comfortable whatever I have on when I
come home I take it off and I put on
this and then I feel comfortable um
today I started my writing I started
yesterday actually and what I'm finding
is that writing on my iPad is really
handy because I have a Korean I'm not
gonna show you but I have a Korean
keypad on the iPad problem with a Korean
alphabet the keypad whether it's on my
computer here on the iPad is that you
know I can't kind of type freehand like
this with ten fingers I have to kind of
point at each little squiggly and kind
of put them together to form the words
and I'm learning how to do that if I do
it on the computer I have to do it with
my mouse if I do it on the iPad I just
do it you know pointing at them so it's
really a lot handier and I use Google
Documents or Google flash whatever they
call it Google Drive and so that I've
got a document in Google Drive so if I'm
working on a on my computer I can add
sentences to it and if I'm working on
the iPad wherever I am I'm adding
sentences and I hope to accumulate a
whole bunch of sentences but then I will
submit for correction at this point I'm
still training myself in writings it's
all new to me so I'm actually you know
copying sentences where there's Korean
and English I read the sentence then I
read the English and I try to recreate
the the Korean but of course I'm not so
familiar yet to some of the composite
you know words in Korean so I'm always
cheating and looking at the Korean so it
it won't really require correction but
I'm hoping that after a couple of days
I'll start creating my own text again
writing the trouble is finding time like
today again I had hockey this morning
then this afternoon had to go an hour
away to Richmond ought to be on a
Chinese radio program was a follow-up to
that discussion we had about investor
immigrants and so forth I was on Chinese
radio of course I listened and again I'm
listening to rock
and half the time when I'm driving
because of the events heating up in
Ukraine got in a little bit of Korean
listening then I got home I was gonna
write some Korean and I go to Shuster
live which is this Ukrainian television
program out of Kiev and I tell you that
was an absolutely fascinating program if
anyone goes to Shuster live if you
understand you Russian and I'm
understanding more and more Ukrainian
and they had first of all they had a
group of six high school students from
Donetsk eastern Ukraine where they have
all the troubles right now who had
visited Lyubov in the western Ukraine
the Ukrainian speaking part a week
earlier and then they had some you
Ukrainian speaking mainly you know
Western Ukrainians who had spent a
weekend done yet so they were there to
talk a little bit about you know their
perspective based on their experience
and this exchange had been organized by
the Donbass hockey team which is in the
KHL the Kontinental Hockey League which
is primarily in Russia but also in Czech
Republic and elsewhere and so and so
they had the captain who his name is
Fedor tanka in Russian but it was known
as Fedotenko when he played and he's
twice won a Stanley Cup in the NHL and
he's the captain of the team so he was
there and then they had two politicians
from eastern Ukraine they had some
politicians from the western Ukraine
they had shots of the armed groups that
have seized the buildings in Donetsk and
Lugansk proclaiming you know with her
machine guys proclaiming the whatever
was the Nets Republic or Lugansk
Republic and stuff like that and there
was an awful lot and then they had the
former president of the first president
of Ukraine Leonid Kravchuk who speaks
very well I mean the overwhelming if
first of all it really lays bare I mean
people were telling you exactly what
they thought and there's no question
that the eastern Ukrainians were not on
the same page as the Western Ukrainians
and lots of speculation and lots of and
and an expression of like you know let's
kind of find some area of compromise but
it looks very very different you could
see in the facial expressions and I
guess the encouraging
thing was that the that students looked
a lot more sensible than the politicians
encouraging I don't know but for the
future perhaps and that really the
politicians on both sides just messed
things up but it's it's still as drama
with the kids and the movie that you
know the shot that we put the videos of
events and stuff like that I mean it it
was it was amazing so there was an
hour-and-a-half shot that I didn't do
Korean interesting too that we had an
election Quebec were and of course a
major issue in in Ukraine is this
Russian language issue
I mean 50% of the population has Russian
as their native language the Western
Ukrainians want to establish you know
Ukrainian as the language that is their
identity and all this kind of stuff
however fifty percent of the people they
speak Russian as the native language and
yet as I mentioned a while ago the when
venediktov FM asked we interviewed the
Minister of Education of Ukraine he said
that at universities in Ukraine you can
only take courses and Ukraine in an
English no like I don't understand that
that to me for what you know it just
didn't make sense it's I mean even in
Quebec so then I moved to Quebec where
he had an election and language there is
always a big issue identity is always a
big issue and the separatist government
of Quebec and this is a thing that we
have had a separatist government in
Quebec for a good portion of the last 35
years and they have had two referenda
and they're still very you know want to
have another referendum to separate and
quite honest if they separate they won't
be any bloodshed
it'll be like Czechoslovak you know the
Czechs and Slovaks I mean whatever it
doesn't matter like it's not worth
fighting over
it's a matter of what people want to do
and where their interests are economic
interests whatever at any rate the
separatists lost so the Federalist
government the Federalist Party came in
it's interesting that they're the
staunchest separatists are the people 50
and over and that as you work your way
down in age people are less interested
in that because it's a different world
you still have your language protect
your language you can let other people
have their language and you deal with
people and if you're a member of length
you learn different languages and you
deal with people from all over the world
so editing rate with all of that going
on I didn't do much Korea and I have to
admit so I don't know seven days to go I
don't know how far I'll get I'm starting
to run out of gas here because there's
so many other things that I want to do
it's a good thing I really piled in hard
you know in the beginning part hopefully
tomorrow I can crank it up I have a
discussion tomorrow for half an hour
with Clara in Paris who speaks beautiful
French and she's my Korean tutor she's
Korea and I'm gonna do some more writing
and listening and reading and we'll see
what happens thanks for listening bye